[Music]
[Applause]
what was the poll question we went with
in the final hour soon well i went with
one that i didn't ask you about but we
sort of hit it off air a little bit okay
if your finger was bent the wrong way
would you keep it as is or have it
removed
so anthony munoz has a pinky finger
that it points i mean it's a right turn
a heart yeah like a hard right turn yes
yeah
it's uncomfortable for us to look at but
for anthony munoz a pretty tough guy is
it uncomfortable with day-to-day life or
is he so used to it that it's
no longer uncomfortable
see like when i look at a hand like that
yeah and your pinky is like headed you
know due east or west right
i would imagine it getting caught on a
lot of things and that would really
drive me crazy because it can't really
serve a functional purpose anymore right
or like just think about every time you
go to put on gloves yes every time that
you go to open a doorknob or a car door
or something like that just i would
imagine it always being in the way
ross tucker played the position our good
buddy here
let's look at your fingers are they
deformed at all
no maybe that's why i wasn't as good as
those other guys
look your hands look like a baby like
they're pristine my hands are fine i
don't have big hands you're right about
that well dan to be fair
i have a huge head
so like i gotta go closer with my hands
to the camera maybe
um but no in all sincerity um i have
really short arms i was not
a great puncher which is important it's
why i was not a great pass protector so
i dislocated my thumb
i remember the first day with the
cowboys that dissipated this finger
and they had to pop it back in
but i don't i never had it go left turn
or right turn but those guys there's a
lot there's receivers uh also see and
there's receivers that have fingers go
torry holt has a finger
going in a crazy direction but i don't
know that i've ever heard any of those
guys
actually remove it i think
it ends up being functional in its own
way they get so used to it they know how
to like use the right angle like
they probably can hold a beer can better
than like you realize they just put it
in between the uh they got their own cup
holder
all right
and i'm i i want this i want you to know
this coming from a good place
with due respect to you that you played
you played the game all right we had
anthony munoz on
make a case might be the greatest
offensive lineman in history
so the difference between you
playing in the nfl playing offensive
line and munoz playing offensive line
but being a first battle hall of famer
like what are the traits
that he has had that you didn't or you
know what's the separation there with
being in the nfl and then going to the
hall of fame
yeah so very fair question and i would
say
put munoz to the side for a second dan
the difference between a starter like i
started 25 games and played in 45 over
seven years the difference between that
and a guy that starts for over a hundred
games and plays 50 it's not as much as
people think then
it's like if if a game is 70 snaps
uh an elite player a long time starter
they'll do the right thing they'll get a
plus they'll they'll accomplish their
mission
68 snaps whereas a guy like me is maybe
65 66 it's not as many plays as people
realize and by the way those two plays
might not impact the game at all but
it's not as much of a difference as
people think but over time over the
course of the season
that does make a difference
munoz just had absolutely unbelievable
feat
and even being around tony beselli this
weekend i was at the hall i mean tony is
six seven and a quarter
325
had really light on his feet
long arms but ultimately all those
things just enabled him
to do the job better because there's
guys that don't have those physical
characteristics but are just so good
with their technique that it enables
them to still be that good of a player
we often look at the defensive player as
being angry
but offensive linemen
have to play angry but maybe not show
anger
it is that fair to say that
it's a great point dan it's controlled
aggression you know if you watch like
the movies or you see people like ah i'm
gonna kill dude you're gonna whiff a
bunch
like like you can't it sounds good to
i'm just gonna go murder these guys uh
well they're gonna make you miss you go
up against a guy that's shaking you you
know like
uh abosa or aaron donald you can't just
go out there and try to demolish guys
you have to have controlled aggression
you have to pick your spots and honestly
dan i never thought blocking people was
fun even my freshman year in college i
played defense when they moved me to
offense the only thing i thought was fun
and still to this day think is fun
is really trying to put people down like
really try not injure
but what i what i enjoy to the game
people ask me this all the time dan
i miss the money whatever i miss the
camaraderie but i got plenty of friends
i have plenty of beers like i'm fine
with that
dan i miss the violence
i i i
as god is my witness
you can't replicate that anywhere else
in life
i miss running into another human being
as hard as i can
knocking them over and just kind of like
feeling the life come out of their body
and knowing that you just caused them
pain
i don't know why that gave me joy
but it did and i and i missed that i
missed the joy
of physically hurting another human
being and i think it's okay to like
admit that
do you remember a particular pancake or
moment where you're like
that's gonna leave a mark that's gonna
hurt
well you know what i remember dan
the first play of my high school
football career
in 10th grade
it was a sweep to the right i was
playing linebacker
i got blindsided and i got the win
knocked out of me my first play of high
school football
i had never gotten the windock on me
before dan i didn't even know what was
happening i thought maybe i was about to
die i i did not know what was happening
i couldn't breathe the kid went for like
an 80 yard touchdown
and what i remember is once i caught my
breath
and i figured out who did it
all i wanted to do the rest of the game
was kill that kid that's all i wanted to
do
uh but yeah no i i have one
you know this is an interesting story to
tell you in hindsight after what
happened to him
but one of the stories i tell is
2003
i'm starting at right guard for the
buffalo bills we're playing the miami
dolphins
and junior seau
was so good at knowing what was coming
and just being aggressive that it was a
run to the right and dan i pull to the
right and junior seoul comes and jacks
me up in the backfield because he saw
what was coming so he jacks me up and
i'm kind of holding on to him and our
running back travis henry cuts back the
other way and so junior disengages for
me and goes the other way
i have no idea what possessed me to do
this dan like the only my natural
reaction was well i can't hold him
anymore it's gonna be a holding penalty
so as he disengaged
with the hard part of my hand
i hit junior
in the back of his head as hard as i
could and it was like a sniper shot him
like he went like that and he fell down
flat on his face
and he got up
ran over me goes tucker that was bs what
the heck was that huh why are you
laughing and i was like dude you're
going to the hall of fame i just totally
smoked you in the back of the head that
was hilarious and he started laughing
because i that game was on national tv
and i got my buddy said to me after the
game dude we saw you punch sea out in
the back of the head so that was one of
the funny stories where there's a hall
of fame player that referenced that
although now it's weird down with
everything going on with ct and oh yeah
and what happened with junior i i almost
look at that play a little bit
differently now but it's still a funny
story just in the fact that he was mad
at me and then when he saw i thought it
was i said dude you're in the hall of
fame someday i just smoked you in the
back of the head that was amazing it's
ross tucker cbs westwood one color
analyst host of the ross tucker football
podcast who did you meet this weekend
that uh
was
more interesting or
special
then you know what's crazy about it i'm
sitting there during the speeches
and then i was like it it's really a
unique thing
right behind me was doug peterson the
jags current head coach
right in front of me was john robinson
you know the legendary usc and and rams
coach
and here's what's crazy
they tell the people before the speech
they confirm who's sitting where
because espn nfl network want to put
them on tv
so they came over to john robinson and
to tony's college online coach mike
barry and they confirmed their names so
i said to my wife i'm like just so you
know we're going to be on tv so whatever
you want to do like what whatever that
means to you
so i like i sat up in my chair a little
bit dan i like pulled down my polo you
know like i didn't want to have i wanted
to look as tight as possible i didn't
want it to be like all baggy so i'm like
this now here's what's crazy on espn
my head got cut off
my sister-in-law sent a video so all you
could see is like my but i could see on
the board
nfl network
i got a bunch of nfl network time and i
didn't know dan
whether to keep watching
tony in the speech
or to like smile at the camera because i
knew it was a very awkward on because i
wanted as much face time for you guys as
possible sure but everybody else is
facing tony watching the stage and i'm
behind john robinson like
you cheese ball
uh so what's gonna say to you though
right next to me right like two two rows
up with shad khan
my i said i said i'm gonna go say hi to
shot khan my wife's like tell him i like
his mustache i was like yeah he's never
heard that one before that's gonna be my
opening line to the owner of the jags my
wife likes your mustache
robert kraft was right there david
tepper i mean like
if you like football
you need to go to the hall of fame
sometime because it's just like nfl
players
walking around not only the hall of
famers but all the guys that are coming
back to support you know whoever is
getting in like me supporting tony yeah
they're just like walking around
everywhere
did i make miseli's speech
no why
i've been where
are you kidding me
i've been working on baseli for four
years to get him into the hall of fame
you know what
you should have i had that's the only
reason why tony even had me there i
think i didn't play with him i didn't
play for the jags
i think tony literally invited me no we
do some western one games together
he mentioned the local guys i i thought
where he had me sitting because i was
close to john robinson like when the
espn guy was going around like ask i was
like i'm yeah i am ross tucker
like this is ross tucker if he mentions
me in the speech
uh but no he only mentioned the local
guys that i guess went to baton rouge
all the time but yes paulie i i'm
i'm i'm shocked i'm gonna get the
transcript before we make a judgment
reggie jackson mentioned me in his hall
of fame speech at cooperstown
did he really yeah he did
yeah
uh well tony should have mentioned me
before i mentioned you i i i was i went
on every platform i could to say tony
should be in a million times you know
what by the way
i've decided after watching tony
sterling sharp should be in the hall of
fame yes
sterling sharp
is the wide receiver of tony biselli's
left tackle of terrell davis's running
back all right you know that phenomenal
but just had a crazy injury that didn't
allow him to do it for a long time all
right i like that we brought up some
other names um obviously tiki barber uh
otis anderson
um
ricky waters like there's some running
backs roger craig you know i did this
dan i did this on my show on friday you
know what my big takeaway is
there's a lot of guys that could be in
the hall of fame like they're like i had
people calling up and they were saying
zach thomas abs patrick willis i mean
demarcus ware there's a lot of varied
lester hayes the only guy
and most people you look at their resume
and you're like yeah that guy could be a
whole yeah that guy's all famous the guy
i'm not so you have to tell me i i got
three calls on jim plunkett
yeah you think jim plunkett's a hall of
famer
well he never even went to a pro bowl he
was never considered one of the five or
six best but he won two super bowls
see that's the problem it's like eli
i don't think eli was a great
quarterback
he didn't lead the league in anything
but interceptions
so why is he in
if his name is there was a couple years
where eli went to pro bowls and was
considered like there was a few years
back then when jim plunkett played you
went to the pro bowl you didn't make up
an excuse therefore the seventh
alternate gets to go to the pro bowl
plunk it plunkett
is underrated yeah pauline i have a
while today i just found eli manning in
his career in the regular season 117 and
117. he's a 500 quarterback jim plunkett
for his career in the regular season 72
and 72 500 quarterback
isn't that unreal
yeah
i noticed that but my point is dan
there's a lot like joe klecko the guys
that really have it rough are the
seniors candidates because there's a lot
of guys well joe
deserves joe klecko was the best
defensive lineman on the sack exchange
gastineau got all the credit joe you ask
any of those offensive linemen joe
klecko was a man
i mean he was a beast there um
zach thomas one of the smartest players
who's ever played the game
bingo
dan i started at least three games
against zach
he was incredible he was incredible
how instinctive he was
how much he knew what we were running
and you look at his stats
his stats are better than her locker you
know what happens erlocker and dude
erlocker was a great player but urlocker
became the face of the bears
and it's chicago it's a big market yeah
so urlocker gets in right away yeah he
didn't have a better career than zach
thomas did but zach thomas didn't get
you know it wasn't like the marketing
darling that erlocker was no i agree and
it's like joe namath love him
but joe to me was not a hall of fame
quarterback
he got more interceptions than
touchdowns
uh
he had one great moment and it was maybe
the biggest moment in nfl history he
played in new york if he doesn't play if
he plays in cleveland he's not in the
hall of fame
but he played in new york he won that
game he guaranteed it and you go into
the hall of fame so a lot of it is where
you play not not necessarily when as
much as where you play
and
i think that that factors in as well but
you know it it's tricky because not
everybody can get in but i do think that
there are
some glaring omissions and it feels like
every every year we're reminded of that
hey i gotta run uh it's always great
great to talk to you absolutely see you
there see you guys that's ross tucker
cbs westwood one
got a ross tucker football podcast